The 1980s turned out
to be a pivotal decade
in the history of work.
So let's take a look at what
happened during that decade
and why we should care
about these developments
because it will affect the
future of work going forward.
The 1970s are going
to go down in history
as a decade of status quo.
The pressures were building, but
managers and workers and unions
and the government behaved as if
the 1960s and 1950s were still
in vogue.
Unions were declining.
New industries were coming along
with new ways of introducing
flexible job designs.
The economy was experiencing
this high rate of inflation
with no growth in wages.
Labor law was getting outdated.
But Congress couldn't
do anything about it.
So the pressures were building
like this proverbial frog that
was in warm water,
stayed in the water
too long until it
started to boil.
Never jumped out because
the challenges were only
being felt incrementally
until it was too late.
So what happened in the 1980s?
The President of
the United States.
Well, Ronald Reagan
got elected president,
a change from a Democrat to
a conservative Republican
with very strong ideas about
how to run the economy.
The second thing
that happened is
it coincided with the
great recession of 1981
to 1983, where the
effort was to try
to break the back of inflation
by the Federal Reserve Board.
The third thing that
came along in coincidence
with these pressures
was the growth
of Japanese and other
global competition.
Now companies in Japan could
build autos and other products
as productively at lower
cost as the United States
and build them in
high qualities so
that they were strong
competitors to this country.
So what did we see happen?
Well, somewhere in
this time period,
that great social contract from
the 1940s through the 1960s
broke down.
This nice coincidence of
wages and productivity
moving together during
this time period,
you can see it began
to fray in the 70s.
And then after 1980, they
depart, never to return again.
So how did this happen?
Well, again, it starts
with Ronald Reagan.
In the August of 1981, the
air traffic controllers
went on strike illegally.
And Ronald Reagan said
this is an illegal strike.
I'm going to take
decisive action.
I'm going to fire them if
they don't come back to work.
He did so.
He broke that strike
and it fundamentally
changed the tenor
of labor relations.
Companies in the private sector
became much more aggressive,
building on the model
of what Reagan did.
They demanded wage
concessions to try
to become more competitive.
They put in what were
called two-tier contracts.
So new workers were starting
that work at a lower wage
rate than more senior workers.
That, in fact, continues
today in many cases.
Auto workers would
understand this
because new hires
come in about 30% less
than workers who are doing the
same work alongside of them.
And so this persisted.
Basically, what happened is
pattern bargaining, that engine
that helped to spread wage
increases across the economy,
broke down.
The bargaining power that
workers got from strikes
was no longer there.
Strikes became
defensive weapons.
And companies like Greyhound
Bus Lines or Eastern Airlines
where strikes occurred, the
companies either won the strike
or in Eastern's case, the
company went out of business.
And all the jobs were lost.
And so this has continued.
Workers lost their
source of power.
They don't have a new source of
bargaining power in place yet.
And so this social contract
continues to be broken.
The challenge that
we face today,
the challenge as next
generation workers you face,
is to figure out what is a
social contract that might work
in the modern economy for
you as a modern workforce
and for society?
We have not figured
that out yet.
That's going to
be your challenge.